Мирного дня Незламні освітяни незламної
країни сьогодні 16 листопада Запрошуємо
освітянську і батьківську спільноту до
участі у всеукраїнському вебінарі від
команди The Lego foundation для закладів
дошкі шкільної освіти щодо імплементації
проекту створюй з будь-чого Дорогі
колеги захід відбувається у партнерстві
Міністерства освіти і науки України
команди The Lego foundation та
українського інституту розвитку освіти Я
Ольга косенчук кандидат педаггічних наук
доцент начальник відділу дошкільної
освіти українського інституту розвитку
освіти сьогодні буду модератором заходу
дорогі друзі готових рішень немає
кожного дня нові виклики новий досвід
який дозволяє нам з вами рухатися до
перемоги створюю з будь-чого це проект
який дозволяє реалізувати найсміливіші
ідеї і ми про це сьогодні будемо
говорити Як це реалізувати в умовах
війни як це реалізувати в умовах
дистанційної освіти на що потрібно
звертати увагу педагогам а яка участь
батьків дорогі друзі ключова ідея яка
покладена в основу концепції - це
принцип система у грі проте про цей
принцип нам сьогодні будуть розповідати
наші чудові спікери і маю сказати про те
що для реалізації проекту на допомогу
педагогам та батькам була створена
безкоштовна
ресурс-платформа яка містить практичні
ідеї вправи і вони дійсно сприяють
розвитку дитини дошкільного віку
найважливіше що всі матеріали
відповідають базовому компоненту
дошкільної освіти і сьогодні у нас з
вами є унікальна можливість
познайомитися з цим чудовим ресурсом
Дорогі колеги я нагадаю що для участі у
вебінарі ви мали можливість
зареєструватися поставити запитання
спікерам ми вже проаналізували разом з
спікерами ваші запитання будемо
пробувати давати на них відповідь під
час нашого вебінару а також я хочу
нагадати що у вас є можливість поставити
запитання під час прямої
трансляції переконані що ви обов'язково
знайдете відповіді на всі запитання які
у вас є адже сьогоднішній вебінар він
буде
практикоорієнтований І я знаю що спікери
готують для вас дуже багато практичних
завдань саме для того щоб ви мали
можливість відпрацювати це все перед тим
як працювати з
дітками трансляція відбувається на
YouTube каналі Міністерства освіти і
науки України запис буде
розміщений на цьомуж YouTube каналі а
також на сайті Міністерства освіти і
науки України українського інституту
розвитку освіти асоціації працівників
дошкільної освіти Lego foundation ви
можете переглянути в зручний для себе
час матеріали і познайомитися з ними
детальніше Дорогі колеги матеріал є у
вільному доступі
сертифікати учасників непередбачені і
наприкінці вебінару ми з вами
повернемося до тих запитань які ви
сьогодні сформулювали а також
сформулювали під час реєстрації саме для
того щоб наші чудові спікери дали на них
відповіді наші спікери неймовірні
креативні чудові вони захоплюють грою
всіх дітей батьків педагогів і я з
неймовірною приємністю хочу вам
представити команду спікерів які
сьогодні нас познайомлють з новою
програмою створюю з будьчого і Оксана
Рома кандидат педагогічних наук
керівниця освітніх ініціатив за Lego
foundation в Україні пані Оксано вітаємо
вас Олена Шуляк психологіня тренерка
Lego foundation пані Олена Вітаємо
вас і Ольга Гончаренко
вихователь-методист закладу дошкільної
освіти Зірниця міста Суми тренерка The
Lego foundation Дорогі колеги я вам
представила наш такий склад тренерів які
сьогодні будуть з вами працювати ви
готуйте будь ласка свої запитання пишіть
відухки свої враження Для нас це
неймовірно важливо А я зараз з великою
приємністю передаю слово пані Олена вам
так Дякую І ще раз хочемо привітати всіх
наших колег дійсно радіємо можливості
зустрітися сьогодні надихнутися
спілкуванням та познайомитися ще з одним
проектом The Lego foundation Create
enicing що в перекладі означає створюй з
будчого і сама назва цього проекту вона
вже відображає його ключову ідею а алеж
розпочати наше спілкування Ми запрошуємо
з привітання з привітання одне одному і
для того щоб це привітання активізувало
роботу нашого мозку допомогло нам
активно включитися у процес взаємодії ми
пропонуємо зараз у чаті обмінятися
оригінальними осінніми привітаннями одне
з одним і ми всі всією нашою командою
бажаємо кожній учасниці кожному учаснику
нашої зустрічі рясного дощу
ідей жовто-помаранчево
натхнення А які побажання одне для
одного можете запропонувати ви
поділіться ними надихнемося
разом і дійсно Кожен з нас прийшов на цю
зустріч з певними
очікування і для того щоб ми також
обмінялися
очікуваннями припущеннями про те якою
буде наша зустріч сьогодні Ми запрошуємо
кожного з вас також по міркувати Я
сподіваюсь що вже встигли написати
побажання і переходимо до е очікувань е
і ми запишемо ці слова і поділися ними у
чаті за допомогою слів ее
прикметників Напишіть будь ласка ваші
припущення ваші очікування за допомогою
прикметників якою би ви хотіли щоби була
наша зустріч Ми би хотіли щоб вона
дійсно була значущою енергійною
наповненою цікавою творчою Напишіть будь
ласка ваші слова
прикметники
чекаємо вашої реакції ваших слів ваших
припущень ваших очікувань будь ласка
щедро
ділимося нашими припущеннями і
переходимо до наступного
виклику для того щоб зробити дійсно
корисною значущою нашою зустріч що нам
потрібно робити як нам потрібно діяти і
зараз запрошуємо вас також ще раз
звернутись е до свого досвіду
поміркувати і поділитися в чаті
дієсловами про те що потрібно робити для
того щоб зустріч наша дійсно була
активною
наповненою будь ласка Поміркуйте і
поділіться
і сподіваємось колеги Що саме такий
пошук прикметників дієслів а головне
думок допоміг нам активувати роботу
нашого мозку відчути себе в ситуації тут
і зараз а також що важливо налаштуватись
на взаємодію і слово пошук є одним із
ключових слів нашої зустрічі сьогодні і
ми бажає жаємо кожного з вас відчути
себе справжнім дослідником творцем які
творцями дослідниками які роблять
відкриття і отримують новий цікавий
досвід і зараз Запрошуємо до слова
керівницю освітніх ініціатив The Lego
foundation пані Оксану Рому яка допоможе
нам знайти ще більше ключових слів та
напрямів щодо нашої зустрічі сьогодні
пані Оксано Дякую Пані Олено Дякую за
вступну частину за те що побажали нам
рясного дощу ідей Хоча з дощами у нас
восени якось дуже спекотно цієї осеннні
тому я ще бажаю Нехай в наших кімнатах
групових кімнатах ми тот кабінетах Де ми
зараз знаходимося чи вдома буде спекотно
від ідей від інсайтів які ми отримуємо і
від потім від бажання зреалізовувати той
проект про який ми сьогодні будемо
говорити у наших закладах дошкільної о
освіти тож е сьогодні моя задача на цій
зустрічі моє таке завдання допомогти нам
як спільноті закладів дошкільної освіти
познайомитися ближче познайомитися
ближче з нами як з фундацією Lego
надихнути вас і розповісти про проект
Create with anything створюй з будь-чого
а потім вибудувати наші подальші з вами
кроки для нас надзвичайно ресурсним є
спілкування саме закладами дошкільної
освіти і
педагогами-дошкільниками свій шлях як
фундація legго в Україні ми розпочинали
саме з дошкільної освіти у 2010 році на
сьогодні як фундація ми працюємо на
різних ланках і щаблях освіти це
дошкілля це початкова освіта це базова
освіта це заклади післядипломної освіти
це педагогічні університети і
педагогічні коледжі але ключова ідея на
який ба Ланс освіти Ми не працювали - це
імплементація ігрового і діяльнісного
підходів в освітній процес Чому Тому що
в основі ми бачимо всебічно розвинену
особистість цілісно розвинену
особистість ми бачимо майбутнього
громадянина нашої країни нашою місією
фундації Lego є розвивати і надихати
творців завтрашнього Для нас це не
просто високі слова це ті слова за якими
стоять реальні проекти реальні
ініціативи і один з таких проектів ми
сьогодні вам покажемо надзвичайно цінно
для нас як фундації Lego Та фундація яка
є данською фундацією але має уже дуже
багато українського досвіду не тільки
допомагати з тими реформаційними
процесами які є трансформаційними
процесами а також підтримувати
відновлення відбудову і розбудову освіти
України до Сьогодні якщо ми говоримо про
дошкілля Ми як фундація legлего були
присутні у 300 закладах дошкільної
освіти у 15 областях України 15 областей
України зараз ви їх бачите зазначеними
на карті це всі заклади які є учасниками
проекту сприяння освіті що цей проект
передбачає проект передбачає участь
педагогів у програмі професійного
розвитку надзвичайно насичена поглиблена
тренінгова програма щодо імплементації
гри як наскрізного підходу у взаємодії з
дитиною це програма обмінів досвідом між
закладами дошкільної освіти це залучення
закладів до всеукраїнського фестивалю
гри навчання і натхнення пfеest але
сьогодні ми маємо таку можливість не
тільки познайомити вас із проектом
створюю з будь-чого а поширити всі ті
матеріали напрацювання які у нас є до
сьогодні серед усіх закладів дошкільної
освіти серед усіх учасників які до нас
приєдналися і розпочну я сьогодні з того
що одна із ключових таких наріжних
наріжних документів наріжних
дороговказів яким ми послуговуємося
сьогодні є парціальна програма розвитку
дитини від двох до 6сти років через гру
творці майбутнього це програма яка була
схвалена у 2023 році це програма яка є у
вільному доступі абсолютно для всіх
закладів дошкільної освіти Але можливо
не всі ще про неї знають тому сьогодні
ми знайомимо вас з тим що є така
програма е детальніше глибше більше
познайомитися з цією програмою можна на
сайті мо ми пізніше покажемо так ресурси
де це можна де це можна отримати а також
у ваших регіональних інститутах
післядипломної освіти в рамках
спецкурсів і модулів педагогіка гри у
закладі дошкільної освіти де ми також
розказуємо і пояснюємо як працювати з
цією програмою в основі програми метою
програми є всебічний розвиток і
розкриття внутрішнього потенціалу кожної
дитини формування цілісного світогляду
дитини через гру і ще раз наголошу на
тому що ми розглядаємо гру як
насткрізний підхід у взаємодії з дітьми
дошкільного віку не як п'ятихвилинку не
як рутинний момент не як винагороду за
проведене заняття Чи гарно виконану
вправу чи завдання дитину А як спосіб
мислення педагога і спосіб у який
розвивається дитина якщо ми з вами
будемо рухатися далі та рухаємося далі
нашою презентацією ще раз Хочу
наголосити на тому що ми розглядаємо гру
передусім провідний вид діяльності
дитини спосіб мислення педагога але
особливо сьогодні у тій ситуації в якій
перебуває наша країна надзвичайно
важливо повернутися до
природовідповідних механізмів і
інструментів які допомагають дітям
долати кризові ситуації і таким
інструментом науково доведено є гра гра
є універсальною мовою спілкування дити
навіть коли дитина коли не хоче
розповідати про Той травмуючий досвід
який пережила але через гру дитина з
одного боку може допомагати педагогам і
психологам зрозуміти що вона переживає
сьогодні а з іншого боку гра уже є
терапевтичним досвідом і ми як фундація
legлего співпрацюємо з багатьма
інституціями і зокрема з нашими
інститутами післядипломної освіти і
спільно з запорізьким інститутом
післядипломної освіти проводили
дослідження про те як змінилася гра
дітей під час повномасштабного
вторгнення і що ми такий дуже цікавий
факт побачили про те що дуже часто діти
програють воєнні сюжети військові сюжети
і це нормально зважаючи на ті реалії в
яких ми перебуваємо але що відрізняє гру
наших дітей те що діти програють ці
сюжети не з метою завдати комусь шкоди а
з метою захистити свою родину свою маму
тата брата сестру дитячий садок це
говорить про те що ми як дошкільники уже
вибудували такий ціннісний фундамент
вибудовуємо Та на якому розвиваємо і
виховує наших дітей і тому Багато в нас
уже напрацьовано є в дошкіллі і зараз
такий час з одного боку можливо час
кризи час коли не дуже ресурсно і не
дуже легко а з іншого боку завжди час
кризи - це той час коли можна
реалізовувати і потрібно реалізовувати
дуже багато інноваційних проектів
ініціатив ідей бо це той час який сприяє
розвитку і повертаючись до нашої
програми бо ці всі ідеї уже закладені цю
програму творці майбутнього окрім такого
оновленого розширеного і поглибленого
погляду на гру ця Програма також
пропонує дієві поради для кожного
педагога як фасилітувати гру та таке
модне сьогодні слово яке в наших реаліях
з'явилося фасилітація гри але з чим її
їсти І як це робити у дитячому садочку
Ця програма пояснює яким чином
реалізовувати проєктну діяльність у
закладах дошкільної освіти і яка роль
гри у проектній діяльності яким чином
взаємодіяти співпрацювати з батьками і
якщо ми подивимось на цю програму Це не
просто програма а ще й методичні
рекомендації до неї наступний слайд і в
цих методичних рекомендаціях можна
знайти конкретні приклади як ігрових
взаємодій з дітьми так і конкретні
приклади проектної роботи і взаємодії із
батьками можна далі
слайди Так це приклади проектів які
можна побачити і
е проектів як із батьками з дітьми так і
проектів із педагогами в рамках закладу
наступний слайд і ми обіцяли вам що
пояснимо де можна знайти цю програму
відразу тут під час нашого вебінару
можна відсканувати qr-код і ви отримуєте
електронну версію цієї програми
користуйтеся будь ласка знайомтися або ж
зайти на сторінку Міністерства освіти і
науки України і в розділі дошкільна
освіта там також є розміщена Ця програма
наступний слайд будь
ласка і пам'ятаєте я буквально декілька
хвилин тому назад згадала про те що час
кризи - це завжди час для квантових
стрибків це час для інновацій ми як
фундація Lego співпрацюємо з багатьма
освітніми інституціями аналітичними
інституціями у світі і одна з таких
інституції - це аналітичний центр
брукіingс в Сполучених Штатах Америки і
цей аналітичний центр проаналізував 70%
інновацій в освіті формальній і
неформальній освіті в різних куточках
світу дошкільній початкові освіті
базовій освіті на різних континентах
нашої планети і що з'ясували про те що
70% проаналізованих інновацій в освіті
використовують ігровий і діяльнісний
підхід це ті підходи які закладені в
базовому компоненті дошкільної освіти і
це ті підходи які маючи в Україні ми
маємо всі шанси зреалізувати багато
цікавих потрібних інновацій які на часі
далі наступний
слайд окрім програми та парціальної
програми яку ми пропонуємо в Україні
розпочався Пілот пілотування програми
соціально-емоційного розвитку і навчання
веселі друзі наразі цей Пілот
відбувається у 300 закладах дошкільної
освіти з наступного року навчального
року академічного року з вересня 24го ми
розпочнемо поширення цієї програми для
всіх закладів дошкільної освіти це
шведська програма це комплексна програма
яка складається із розроблених
методичних рекомендаці ці для педагога
із мультфільмів і м'які іграшки і
мобільний застосунок який є безкоштовним
для педагогів для батьків для будь-кого
Хто є з України в будь-якому куточку
світу також за покликанням qr-кодом
можна завантажити з Google Play або
Apple Store можна завантажити собі
додаток якщо ви знаходитесь сьогодні не
в Україні або в Україні уже розпочинати
перші кроки на шляху до
соціально-емоційного розвитку разом із
дітьми це те що ми обіцяємо та на
наступний рік і ця програма буде
доступна через регіональні інститути
післядипломної освіти тому моніторте ті
курси які будуть вам пропонуватися в
рамках професійного розвитку але
надзвичайно важливо сьогодні стоє
питання також психосоціальної підтримки
це те з чим ми вже знайомі трішки
знайомі через гіркі обставини які
відбуваються в нашій країні але з іншого
боку ми сьогодні навігуємо у світі який
називають дуже багатьма різними
термінами і вкасві і світ революції
перекваліфікації і світ невизначеності і
постковідна реальність але
психосоціальна підтримка зважаючи на ті
обставини де ми живемо актуальна стає не
тільки сьогодні а завтра і післязавтра
через 20 10 3050 років ми очікуємо що до
2050 року світ буде налічувати Близько 1
мльрда біженців пропонують їх називати
кліматичними мігрантами у зв'язку з тими
кліматичними змінами які відбуваються і
наші діти
я зараз говорю не тільки про українських
дітей я говорю взагалі про дітей світу
будуть переміщуватися з однієї країни до
іншої з одного місця до іншого і нам
надзвичайно важливо як педагогам мати
всі ресурси мати знання і вміння
надавати психосоціальну підтримку але
передусім пам'ятайте що щоб надавати
підтримку комусь потрібно забезпечити
кисневу маску для себе тому разом із
організацію яка називається mhps
коaborative був розроблений курс
благополуччя дітей і педагогів дієві
інструменти і практики психосоціальної
підтримки який на сьогодні є доступний і
в онлайн варіантів і в офлайн варіантів
через регіональні заклади після
дипломної освіти наступний слайд будь
ласка дуже часто і найчастіше те що
запитують усі педагоги дайте нам
практичні матеріали які ми можемо
використати сьогодні тут і зараз і прямо
аж ось зараз тому ще один посібник який
був розроблений для педагогів закладів
дошкільної діти називається граємо разом
це посібник з фасилітації бачите знову
це модне слово ігрової взаємодії з
дітьми дошкільного віку деякі з
прикладів взаємодій ви бачите на екрані
так само на сайті мон є посилання і
доступ у вільному доступі до цих
ресурсів за qr-кодом можна знайти ці
ресурси і на сьогодні ми навіть
розширили цей посібник бо він
розпочинався виключно для онлайн
взаємодії та в березні 22-го року на
сьогодні такі взаємодіїє онлайн і офлайн
і те що також завжди дуже просять
педагоги кожна взаємодія включає блок
секцію взаємодії із батьками що ви
можете пропонувати батькам незважаючи чи
офлайн модальності чи онлайн Ви працюєте
як продовжувати ігрові взаємодії вдома
тому ще один ресурс яким будь ласка
вільно можна користуватися наступний
слайд це сторінка та скрін сторінки із
сайту Міністерства освіти і науки
України в розділі освіта дошкільна
освіта є підрозділ підрубрика діяльність
за Lego foundation у дошкіль України і
тут покликання на всі ті матеріали які я
зазначила Хто не встиг скористатися
qr-кодом можна зайти на сайт мо і
можливо ще багато чого цікавого не
тільки у нас можна на сайті почерпнути
для себе наступний слайд і надзвичайно
важливо бо ми знаємо що у вас є
безпосередній зв'язок з дітьми які зараз
перебувають за кордоном але намагаються
все одно тримати зв'язок з вами нашими
вихователями нам нами спільно з
партнерами мока мока
був створений додаток для вивчення мови
моocama lingva App в основі лежить гра
не потрібно говорити іноземною мовою не
потрібно говорити українською мовою але
цей додаток допомагає з одного боку
дітям підтримувати знання з української
мови а з іншого боку опановувати ту мову
з перелічених на екрані зважаючи на ту
країну у якій дитина на сьогодні
перебуває ми знаємо що Мова - це чинник
національної безпеки надзвичайно важливо
підтримувати зв'язок дітей щоб вони
вивчали навіть іноземни мо але через
українську мову тому був такий створений
додаток який також є у вільному доступі
наступний слайд будь
ласка а сьогодні те що в нас буде
відбуватися та те зчим ми будемо вас
знайомити Це перша ініціатива яку
ми якою ми виходимо за межі проекту
сприяння освіті яка називається проект
створюй з будьчого англійською мовою
Create with anything і тут хочу передати
слово нашим тренеркам які допоможуть нам
за туритися саме в цей проект і відразу
Хочу зазначити що цей проект можна
використовувати ресурси цього проекту як
в онлайн так і офлайн взаємодії як
заняття в групових кімнатах так і в
укритті що надзвичайно є важливим для
нашої освітянської реальності сьогодні
так пані Олена будь ласка Так Дякуємо
пані Оксано вам за ті напрями які ви
окреслили і за ті ресурси про які ви
розказали Сподіваємось що вже колеги
встигли перейти за qr-кодами відкрити
для себе ці ресурси адже надзвичайно
важливо сьогодні вміти діяти тут і зараз
а Ми продовжуємо наше знайомство з
унікальним Міжнародним проектом Create
with enising від The Lego foundation і
хочемо познайомити вас з ідеєю яка
народилася у 2018 році ідеї створення
цього проекту під час зустрічі з
партнерами колеги з alo foundation
відвідали місцеву лабораторію гри
playlab вони там мали змогу знайомитися
з досвідом педагогів і Під час цієї
зустрічі вони долучилися до ігрової
взаємодії з дітьми де педагогам колегам
де педагогами було продемонстровано 25
однакових аплікацій да слайд ви можете
побачити
трішечки цього досвіду і ключове слово в
цьому
однакових поміркуємо зараз разом а чому
на вашу думку аплікації були
однаковими і тут важливо ще згадати про
місію з Lego foundation і ця місія
звучить так надихати і розвивати твірців
завтрашнього саме тому колеги з Lego
foundation розпочали пошук способів та
інструментів як змінити підходи до
ігрової взаємодії з дітьми надаючи дітям
можливість пропонувати власні ідеї
реалізувати їх як створити можливості
для ігрової взаємодії з дітьми з
доступних кожному матеріалів і таким
чином народилась ідея проєкту створю з
будьчого і хочемо зазначити що головна
мета проєкту - це сприяти укоріненню гри
як наскрізного підходу в освітньому
процесі створення освітнього простору
для навчання і всебічного розвитку дітей
доступних ко матеріалі адже гра як
підхід - це відкрита система яка
передбачає самостійний пошук дитиною
відповіді на виклик а невиконання
готових інструкцій та відтворення за
шаблоно в Україну цей проект прийшов у
2021-2022 році навчальному і його
пілотування відбувалося у 29 закладах
дошкільної та загальної середньої освіти
України та також пані Ольга на самому
початку сьогодні говорила про те що в
основі цього проєкту лежить концепція
System inpl система в грі і
ее це про те що Кожен елемент частина
може мати безліч варіантів з'єднань з
іншими матеріалами ми можемо поєднувати
папір картон пластик і створювати все
нові і нові ідеї для ігрової взаємодії
як це буде на практиці Ми сьогодні
відчуємо на власной до на власному
досвіді під час ігрової взаємодії і
сподіваємось колеги Що ви встигли
підготувати до нашої зустрічі сьогодні
всі необхідні
матеріали і
використовуючи ці матеріали які є
підручними Ми маємо можливість не тільки
реалізувати певну ідею Наприклад ми
можемо створити тварину а по потім і
трансформувати цю
ідею змінюючи деталі додаючи елементи
декор оформлення або створити щось
абсолютне інше Наприклад якщо слону
замість вуха Ми додамо хвіст ім'я мала
така тварина
ее
яка якщо би ми змінили повністю всі
деталі яка би вигадена тварила в нас
тварина у нас вийшла яку би суперсилу
вона мала і саме ця ідея вона допомагає
нам не створити 25 однакових тварин а
втілити будь-яку свою унікальну ідею і
за потреби потім її трансформувати в
щось абсолютно інше І це ще раз
підтверджує що навколо нас є безліч
можливостей і завдання педагога є
навчити дітей бачити ці можливості і
вміти їх
використати ще хочеться сказати про
унікальність концепції проекту Create
viені і вона полягає у вихованні
екологічної свідомості дитини важливості
і та
цінності помилки як невід'ємної
складової розвитку коли діти працюють за
інструкцією за шаблоном вони є просто
виконавцями в такому разі коли виконують
просто вказівку вони не є творцями але
саме творці маючи право на помилку
можуть досліджувати відкривати
експериментувати щось нове для себе
дізнаватися І що ключове- бути сміливим
адже реальність сьогодні вона вже
сьогодні потребує тих людей які можуть
діяти не за шаблонами бути
відповідальними за власні ідеї та
рішення не боятися зробити помилку і
можуть впливати на зміни у власному
житті і на ЗМІ в освіті навколо і всі ці
вміння і навички ми починаємо розвивати
ще з дошкілля чи може стати творцем
майбутнього дитина яка є виключно
виконавці виконавцем інструкції дорослих
і не має простору і можливостей
пропонувати реалізувати власні
ідеї згадаймо про 25 однакових
аплікацій коли ми говоримо про проект
creing то ми говоримо про те що діти
мають можливість реалізувати
найсміливіші ідеї знову повторюють те що
це можна зробити використовуючи тими
теми ті матеріали які є довкола як в
закладі освіти так і вдома разом з
батьками і для того щоб продовжити е ще
глибше познайомитись і побачити Ми
пропонуємо вам переглянути відео будь
ласка коротке відео для ваш до вашої
уваги
[музика]
так сподіваюсь що зацікавило вас це
відео і вже хочеться дізнатися щось
більше і це це відео воно розпочинає
знайомство з платформою Create with
enison яка є невід'ємною частиною цього
проєкту і вона доступна тими мовами в
країнах яких вона імплементується а саме
англійською іспанською португальською
китайською а також що надзвичайно
важливо для нас українською і ця
платформа була розроблена для того щоб
допомогти дорослим створити простір гри
з дітьми і вона нам допоможе можливо
більш глибоко зрозуміти суть проєкту і
що важливо також для нас вона містить
практичні ідеї і ці ідеї можуть стати
для нас трампліном для розгортання
ігрової взаємодії І ми вас запрошуємо на
віртуальною екскурсію платформою
createening і вашим гідом буде сьогодні
моя колега тренерка за Lego foundation
Ольга Гончаренко Оль передаю вам слово
дякую Олена А я від Вітаю всіх учасників
сьогоднішньої нашої зустрічі І запрошую
вас краще пізнати і дослідити ресурси
платформи Create with anythinging ви
можете відсканувати qr-код або
слідкувати за нашим екраном А пізніше
вже вивчати ресурси самостійно
е ви вже переглянули відео воно є
найпершим для того щоб мати уявлення про
те що ж вас чекає Якщо ви будете
занурюватися далі у
проект для того щоб
продовжити рух платформою ви можете
використовувати кнопку старт або кнопку
меню як сказала
Олена платформа доступна декількома
мовами і саме ось тут ви можете обрати
ту мову Яка вам найкраща Ми обираємо
нашу рідвну українську мову
а повторюсь може
що платформа є невід'ємною частиною
проекту і була розроблена щоб допомагати
дорослим створювати освітній простір для
гри з дітьми і сприяти їх всебічному
розвитку і ви бачите зараз на платформі
фото які добре це підтверджують адже
захоплені очі дітей - це найважливіше що
має бути у наших
закладах платформа містить три розділи і
зараз ми з ними більш детальніше
познайомимося перший розділ - це основні
елементи і У цьому розділі ви можете
знайти шаблони для створення конекторів
моторів трафаретів та фонів обираючи
наприклад шаблони геометричних фігур у
розділі трафарети ви можете
завантажувати їх Ось так і маєте конкрет
інструкцію як далі діяти для того щоб
використати дані фігури у творчості
оскільки Зазвичай діти не обмежуються
стандартними фігурами то тут же можна
знайти і шаблони інших форм теж
пропонуються вони але звичайно не
забуваємо про творчість і можна навіть
не використовувати ніяких шаблонів а
діяти за покликом серця і так як діють
руки дитини Чи ви як дорослий можете їй
в цьому
допомагати в основних елементах теж
можна познайомитися з різними типами
фонів які саме фони можуть бути ми
можемо переглянути тут теж це ширма
декорація екран відповідно до віку і
можливості дітей ви разом з ними будете
обирати най кращий і найвдаліший фон для
розгортання ігрових взаємодій і спільно
з дітьми їх створювати найкраще це
підходить для дітей старшого дошкільного
віку але є і елементи для старших дітей
наприклад такі у розділі мотори
використовуються більш уже складніші
інженерні конструкції і це вже більше
підійде дітям у
школі
наступнийроз л який є на наш на нашій
платформі це ідеї для створення і Саме
тут ви можете познайомитися із ідеями
для створення 2D героїв та персонажів це
можуть
бути тварини люди об'ємні і необ'ємні
герої що рухаються унікальні якісь герої
декорації різноманітні важелі для
управління
героями наприклад для театралізованих
ігор у
дошкільному закладі ось такий вигляд
вони
мають так а у третьому розділі платформи
втілюємо ідеї представлена різноманітна
тематика проєктів яка надихне вас
створювати власні і реалізувати власні
задуми Ось на на приклад одна з них
осінь у
саду Ось так є для завантаження кнопка
яку ви можете використовувати і
знайомитися далі що ж пропонує вам саме
ця платформа ресурси
платформи зараз же я пропоную вам ближче
познайомитися з основними елементами які
допоможуть нам поєднувати деталі а саме
конекторами повертаємося у розділ
основні елементи розділ конектори І тут
ви можете бачити різні види
е-е які будуть потрібні для різних видів
з'єднань перший - Це
серфконектор ось такий конектор овальний
у формі дошки для серфінгу тому і має
таку назву він підходить для з'єднання
простих деталей і для того щоб зробити
серфконектор е більш міцним і гнучким
можна використовувати різноманітний
пластик це можуть бути різні пляшечки
е-е також можна використовувати звичайно
і картон для серфконектору е ось такий у
мене серфконектор картонний А на фото на
платформі ви бачите саме пластиковий
гнучкий і більш цубкий
конектор наступний конектор 3D кутовий
конектор е Ось він має Такий вигляд і з
досвіду роботи можу сказати що це
складний такий для створення
3d-конструкцій міцних конструкцій і за
допомогою такого 3d-конектора е можна
з'єднувати е частини різніх фігур для
того щоб створювати об'ємні фігури Але у
дошкільному закладі цей конектор є
складнуватим для дітей тому ми
використовуємо більше серфконектор і
конектор зірку саме конектор зірку
Ми пропонуємо вам зараз виготовити разом
із
нами як же ми можемо це
зробити для цього вам
підійде картон наприклад із коробки
з-під чаю або наприклад обкладинка
зошита Тобто це такий не дуже цупкий
але достатньо твердий папір
картонний що нам треба зробити з картону
нам треба вирізати смужку шириною 2 см і
довжиною 4 см так як ви бачите зараз це
і на фото а для виготовлення для
полегшення роботи вам є інструкції є
шаблони для скачування і Ось таким чином
ви можете познайомитися Як же
виготовляти конектор зірочку яка нам
сьогодні допомагатиме
створювати і реалізувати наші ідеї
Як ви вже побачили нам треба подовшому
краю ножицями розрізати е до не доходячи
до середини десь 2-3 мм
розрізати на такі вузенькі
смужечки це треба зробити з обох сторін
так як ви зараз це Бачите
на фото Ось таким чином після того як
смужечка буде Ось таким чином порізана
вам треба її щільно
Згорнути ось в такий маленький
циліндр ось такий конектор в мене вийшов
ви можете також роздивитися його
детальніше на платформі
нашій ці елементи які ви розрізали і
будуть саме скріплюючим елементом для
тих деталей які ми будемо вико стовувать
і в подальшому
скріплювать хочемо зазначити що педагогу
варто враховувати час необхідний для
виготовлення конекторів і от до цієї
роботи можна залучати батьків адже
надзвичайно важливо комунікувати і
співпрацювати з батьками Як активними
учасниками освітнього
процесу А я сподіваюся ви вже змогли
виготовити один конектор але для нашої з
вами сьогоднішньої роботи нам
знадобиться їх два тому будь ласка
зробіть Такі ж самі маніпуляції з
шматочком картону е повторюю 2 см на 4 е
розрізаємо по краях не доходячи до
середини і міцно стискаємо виготовляючи
ось такий
конектор ви звичайно можете стати і
творцями власних конекторів для
з'єднання деталей при цьому основна
основне правило Ми не використовуємо
клей степлер скотч і будь-які ті
матеріали які раніше допомагали нам
скріплювати деталі бо ми будемо
працювати саме
ее із System inpl тобто будемо
з'єднувати деталі і роз'єднувати їх з
допомогою
конекторів
Я сподіваюся що ви вже встигли зробити
два конектори зірочки якщо ще не встигли
То можете продовжувати
але паралельно і слухати що відбувається
тут у нас зараз прошу вас поглянути на
слайд Як ви думаєте що ж спільного у
всіх цих зображеннях
об'єктів Напишіть будь ласка про це у
чаті
І звісно ж на всіх цих об'єктах
зображені
ґдзики є такий ось цікавий пам'ятник
гудзику є красиві
декоровані об'єкти саме
гудзиками сьогодні на нашій зустрічі
гудзики з'явилися не просто так адже
саме Сьогодні 16 листопада у світі
відзначається день
ґудзиків а Чи можете ви побачити зараз
на своєму одязі чи у просторі біля вас
ґудзики якщо побачили то напишіть будь
ласка якого кольору ваші ґудзики І що у
природі буває такого ж кольору наприклад
на моїй сукні бронзові ґудзики і вони
такого ж кольору як опале осіннє
листя То нащо ж схожі ґдзики за кольором
ваші дітям ми могли б запропонувати
такий виклик знайти ґудзики на своєму
одязі або на одязі товаришів або
наприклад у просторі і потім у парах
обговорити якого вони кольору і що у
природі буває такого кольору Можливо
вони блакитні як небо чи зелені як трава
чи червоні як стигла калина а Зверніть
будь ласка увагу на форму ґдзиків Ось на
цьому
слайді які геометричні форми були
використані для виготовлення таких
кудзиків як називаються ці геометричні
фігури на які вони схожі за формою і ви
справді можете бачить різноманітні
ґудзики вони бувають і круглі і
квадратні і прямокутні і можуть мати
форму овала ромба трикутника різні різні
різні А якби ви створювали дизайнерський
гуудзик то яку форму Ви б могли йому
надати Напишіть будь ласка у
чаті можливо ваш ґудзик буде у формі
ягоди чи
гриба може він буде у формі олівця чи
квітки поділіться вашими ідеями
креативних
ґудзиків і ми зараз не просто
розглядаємо ґудзики бо ми зараз
спробуємо виготовити ґудзик з картону е
ви до нашої зустрічі підготували різні
картонні пакування як я вже сказала від
солодощів чаю Ось такі ось такі
абсолютно
різноманітні У мене сьогодні для своєї
роботи я використаю ось таку картонну
коробку для взуття і обкладинки цубки
обкладинки використаних
зошитів і вже в цей час наш мозок
починає шукати варіанти рішень на
отриманий виклик І у вас уже можуть
з'являтися ідеї які будуть змінюватися в
процесі творення тож
розпочинаймо Для початку я пропоную вам
на картуні намалювати
гуудзик я малюватиму олівцем для того
щоб мати
можливість старти і спробувати знову
якщо мені прийде інша ідея у процесі
творення
А я також можу поміняти і матеріал з
якого хочу виготовити гуудзик взяти
інший картон більш щільний чи навпаки
більш Гладкий або такий який має певне
зображення яке мені подобається чи
більше підходить для мого задуму От
наприклад Якби я зараз виготовляла
Гудзик квіткою то я б обрала саме
обкладинку цього зошита адже тут таке
розмаїття квітів саме якусь би із них Я
обрала для свого
Ґудзика але в мене інша Інша
ідея моя ідея - Це Гудзик смайл ось
такий Я буду сьогодні виготовляти Гудзик
смайл за допомогою ножець я виріжу
намальований
кудзик а потім з допомогою
гіркопроколювача
дірко прокулювича
зроблю отвір на місці отворів у гуудзику
моєму ось
так І ось такий у мене Гудзик вже вийшов
Гудзик
[музика]
смайл Я б могла його продовжити
удосконалювати розмалювати його
кольоровими олівцями чи
фломастерами прикрасити наліпками
блискітками чи іншими матеріалами для
творчості з досвіду роботи з дітьми я
можу сказати що дітям дуже подобається
процес створення який починається з
можливості обирати матеріали для
виготовлення самостійно придумувати та
реалізувати власну ідею і знаходити
власні рішення експериментувати а не
просто отримати готові деталі і зібрати
їх за запропонованим
зразком якщо ви вже створили свій Гудзик
на лювали його вирізали то у чаті
поставте будь ласка смайл який передає
ваш настрій саме
зараз Якби така взаємодія була
запропонована дітям діти б могли
показати створені ґудзики у парах у
командах показати свої емоційні реакції
які виникли у них в процесі творення і
ось така взаємодія у парах і командах є
дуже важливою адже діти мають можливість
презентувати власну ідею бачите які ідеї
реалізували інші підтримувати одне
одного
і порадіти
разом Подивіться зараз будь ласка на
Гудзик який ви створили і Поміркуйте А
до якого б одягу він міг би
пасувати напишіть про це у чаті про ту
назву одягу до якого пасував би ваш
ґудзик Я думаю що мій Гудзик майл
пасував би а пасував би до шкарпетки це
зробило б мій образ креативним і
унікальним і мій ґзик у цьому випадку
буде слугувати більше декором або
прикрасою А як ви розумієте що ґдзик
може бути застіпкою і тоді ми його
розмістимо на ковтині чи сорочці він
буде з'єднувати елементи одягу застібати
сорочки ковтинки кишені і так
далі а-а і я не просто так пригадала про
одяг Намалюйте зараз той одяг на картоні
який пасуватиме е до якого пасуватиме
щойно створений ваш
ґудзик я для малювання одягу для
створення одягу використаю саме ось цю
коробку велику і спробую намалювати сві
свою
шкарпеточку А ви зробіть саме той одяг
який вам найбільше до
вподоби
е звичайно дітям може знадобитися в
цьому випадку допомога дорослого
особливо коли мова йде про з'єднання
деталей ее можливо ваша допомога
знадобиться дитині коли необхідно буде
зробити отвір за допомогою
діркопробивача адже необхідно розуміти
де саме він має бути для подальшого
зручного з'єднання деталей конектором
але Пам'ятайте про
те що не варто робити за дитину те що
вона може зробити сама а сама Вона може
знайти рішення поекспериментувати
випробувати і створити щось
самостійно Тож наш одяг вже я думаю
намальовано і нам треба буде знову ж
таки вирізати його за допомогою ножиць і
вирішити де ж буде розташований ваш
ґудзик за допомогою конектора зірочки
який ви створили ми будемо приєднувати
Гудзик до одягу Ось таким чином я
з'єдную е свій Гудзик смайлик і свою
шкарпеточку ее на одній відстані
діркопроколювач зроблені отвори і Я
вставляю ось конектор саме в цей
отвір елементи які ви розрізали ми
розрівнюємо Таким
чином деталі наші будуть міцно
поєднані Ось так вже Гудзик ніде не
дінеться він вже міцно тримається але я
закріплю його іще одним конектором адже
ми їх створювали два Таким чином ми наче
пришиваємо Гудзик
Ось таким
чином я хочу трішечки оздобити свій
смайл
Гудзик намалювати йому Ось
такі ось такий у мене вийшов смайлик
гуцик на
шкарпетці така креативна шкарпетка у
мене
вийшла Я думаю що і у вас вийшли чудові
е-е
гудзики
із
гарними
ідейками якби наприклад мені треба було
підготуватися до свята не ґдзика а
наприклад до свята зберігання таємниці я
б робила ґудзик у формі м наприклад у
формі замка і за допомогою конекторів
знову ж таки змінювала декор шкарпетки
тобто конектор просто дістаємо і можемо
замінювати Ось таким чином один ґдзик на
інший елемент Якби ми не виготовляли
наприклад ґдзики а просто робили декор
для шкарпетки ми б могли кілька
виготовити таких елементів для декору це
могли б бути якісь геометричні фігури чи
інші елементи але важливо що вони мають
змогу змінюватися тобто бути змінними і
постійно удосконалювати і покращувати
ту той одяг який би Ми
прикрашали якби ми пропонували таку
взаємодію дітям то ми б разом з ними
поміркували а Хто б міг носити такий
одяг От наприклад Хто б міг
носити ваш одяг який створили ви
наприклад хтось Іка героїв чи персонажів
мультфільмів от я думаю що моя шкарпетка
точно підійшла для Пеппі довгої панчухи
Бо вона така ж весела грайлива креативна
і точно б зраділа такій речі
помаранчевого кольору жовтим гудзиком
така яка несе енергію радість
веселощі А ви можете поділитися тим де
хто без казкових героїв використав саме
ваш
одяг продовжуючи взаємодію з дітьми Ми б
могли запропонувати створити наприклад
казковий показ мод або облаштувати
крамничку дизайнерського одягу або
запропонувати дітям самостійно придумати
Що б вони хотіли робити зі створеними
речами А які б ідеї продовження такої
взаємодії запропонували ви поділіться
учатя
надзвичайно важливо для професійного
розвитку ділитися думками та ідеями і
саме ті ідеї якими ви поділитеся зараз є
цінними для усієї педагогічної спільноти
адже саме вони можуть доповнити наше
професійне портфоліо і бути реалізоване
у взаємодії з дітьми вже
завтра така практична реалізація
учасниками якої Ми щойно були допомагає
нам реалізовувати гру як підхід і
сприяти цілісному розвитку дитини а це є
одним із основоположних завдань базового
компоненту дошкільної освіти А більш
детально проаналізувати Той досвід який
ви щойно отримали Я знову запрошую свою
колегу Олену
оленочко дякую
дякую врний досвід використання гудзиків
конекторів дуже цікаво і дійсно ми маємо
як педагоги практики вміти і аналізувати
Той досвід до якого ми були долучені і
дійсно ми маємо мати орієнтири для того
щоб розуміти чи той підхід чи то та
взаємодія дійсно є ігровою взаємодіє і
ми
маємо такі важливі орієнтири до яких ми
зараз вернемось я думаю що заклади які є
учасниками проекту сприянню освіти
учасники які вже долучались до вебінарів
чули про характеристики гри Можливо ви
вчитали це в програмі про яку йшла
сьогодні мова і ви можете побачити ці
характеристики зараз на слайді дійсно ми
зараз будемо говорити про орієнтири для
того щоб ми могли вибудовувати нашу
взаємодію в ігровому підході про
характеристи гри і перша характеристика
про яку ми пропонуємо згадати - це
значуща коли діяльність дитини пов'язана
з її досвідом життям середовищем
значущість - це те що знаходить відгук
дитини і допомагає вирішити певний
виклик поєднати е свої вже знання вміння
і бажання з тим новим Що приходить в її
життя а що ж було значущим у тій
взаємодії яку ми Запропонували для вас
щойно для дитини тема одягу і гуциків -
це те що оточує її щодня це те що
пов'язано із досвідом і життям і
завдання дійсно містили цікаві виклики
які передбачали і спілкування дітей між
собою а також давали дітям можливість
реалізувати власні ідеї і власні
задуми наступна характеристика про яку
хочемо згадати - це соціальна
характеристика робота в парах і командах
дозволяє кожній дитині стати активним
учасником а не бути пасивним
спостерігачем тож соціальна
характеристика з'являється тоді коли
діяльність відбувається у взаємодії
дітей одне з одним а також
дорослим коли педагог є фасилітатором а
діяльність відбувається дітей у парах
або в командах і е слово модне
фасилітатор про яке сьогодні говорили да
ще раз його згадуємо і дітям дійсно
важливо ділитися думками одне з одним
обговорювати ідеї спільно шукати рішення
на виклик сперечатися можливо
домовлятися шукати спільне що важливо е
вміти підтримувати одне одного радіти
один за
одного А яким чином соціальна
характеристика проявлялась у ій
взаємодії до якої Ми щойно були долучені
дійсно ми працювали онлайн і наша
взаємодія відбувалась через чат А якщо
би ми пропонували таку взаємодію таку
активність дітям то ми би дійсно
працювали в парах в командах одне з
одним із педагогам і таким чином ця
характеристика соціальна характеристика
була би яскраво
вирашена наступна характеристика радісна
і в цьому колі хара ристик про які ми
згадуємо Вона займає таке саме важливе
почесне місце як і інші характеристики
адже без радості розвиток дитини не
відбувається діяльність для дитини має
бути радісною почуття радості активує
хімічний процес вироблення в організмі
дитини нейромедіатора допаміна і саме
допамін відповідає за наполегливість
когнітивну діяльність вміння перемикати
уваги за мотивацію А якщо рівень м
допаміну буде недостатнім то дитина буде
відчувати перед напругою стрес
сповільнюватися будуть і
загальмовуватися когнітивні процеси
обмежуватися рухова діяльність і ще раз
хочемо наголосити що когнітивна
діяльність може відбуватися лише за
умови емоційного залучення дитини коли
діти відчувають радість вони дійсно
здатні концентрувати уваги і бути
активно включеними в процес
важливий момент на який Варто звернути
вашу увагу це те що радісна
характеристика не дорівнює розвага це
про те що дитина емоційно включеня в
пошук рішення на виклик на той цікавий
виклик який вона отримує
і тому радісна характеристика ми як
говорили так само важлива як і інша
наступна
характеристика Так це ми зараз бачимо на
слайді ті ті речі про які говорили про
нейромедіатор допамін так наступна
характеристика мотивуюча і коли ми
говоримо про мотивуючу
характеристику ми говоримо про
можливість для дитини пробувати знову і
знову шукати шляхи рішення мати право на
помилку не очікувати
інстрових готових інструкцій і рішень а
починати з новими вміти починати з ми
припущеннями та ідеями наприклад я
зробила Гудзик
ее одягла його да конектором до
шкарпетки пришила його до шкарпетки і
мені не сподобалось Я зрозуміла що цей
Гудзик наприклад завеликий або жовтий
колір мені не подобається не пасує і я
розумію що я можу зробити інакше або
можливо взагалі я відмовляюсь від цієї
ідеї і вже не використовую Гудзик
змайлик роблю Гудзик вишеньку і
е можу її зробити поміняти цю ідею і оце
е і є про мотивуючу характеристику Коли
ми можемо починати знову і знову з
новими ідеями та
припущенням наступна характеристика про
яку варто зауважити - це
активна коли ми говоримо про активну
характеристику коли ми можливо чуємо
слово активна то перше що може спадати
нам на думку це такі слова як рух біг
фізичні вправи тренування тобто фізична
активність але ця характеристика
набагато ширша і глибша і окрім і
передусім ми маємо на увазі активну
ментальну включеність дитину у процес
пізнання у діяльність до якої вона
залучена у те що відбувається з нею і
навколо неї і і дитина має бути активним
учасником процесу А як ж як же була
виражена ця характеристика у ціій
взаємодії до до якої ми були щойно
залучені активна характеристика була
наскрізні вона яскрава була виражена
коли ми визначали що об'єднує вссі
зображення на слайді коли ми шукали
гудзики в просторі і на одязі коли ми їх
досліджували коли ми створювали
дизайнерські гудзики коли ми
розмірковували частиною чого вони є і
так
далі Зараз ми з вами згадали про п'ять
характеристик гри
ее проаналізували яким чином ці
характеристики були виражені в наші
ігровій активності і ще хочемо додати що
всі ці характеристики е вони не
обов'язково мають бути одразу і на
кожному кроці присутні у всіх у всій
взаємод ді всій гровій взаємодії з
дітьми але ми як педагоги можемо
чергувати і ступінь їхньої вираженості
але ключовим все-таки є їхня присутність
Саме ці характеристики є
індикаторами Які нам допомагають
зрозуміти яким чином ми вибудовуємо
взаємодію з дітьми і далі ми маємо за
допомогою цих характеристик бути дійсно
дизайнерами проектувати взаємодії і е-е
створювати власні ідеї у для гри у своїх
у своїх професійних практиках
е-е далі Коли ми говоримо про те що гра
як підхід вона спрямована на цілісний на
всебічний розвиток дитини і коли ми
говоримо що ми вибудовуємо ігрову
взаємодію ми можемо орієнтуватися на
характеристики але
коли ми говоримо про всебічний цілісний
розвиток дитини ми маємо ще Пам'ятати
про те які сфери розвитку дитини ми
розвиваємо це і креативна сфера і
соціальна і Фізична і емоційна і
когнітивна і надзвичайно важливо також
усвідомлювати що не може бути перекосу в
один бік чи в інший бік А розвиток
дитини має бути саме цілісним і
збалансованим і са тому коли
ми втілюємо якусь ідею в життя і
запропонуємо ігробу взаємодію з дітьми
Ми можемо орієнтуватися чи передбачає
така ігрова взаємодія креативний
розвиток дитини соціальний розвиток
фізичний емоційний пізнавальний розвиток
дитини і це також є таким орієнтиром для
нас як для педагогі ще раз хочемо
наголосити що ще більше дізнатися про
характеристи
про сфери розвитку дитини ви можете
знайти всю цю інформацію у програмі
розвитку дитини від двох до 6сти років
яка має як на мене просто магічну назву
творці
майбутнього тож будь ласка звертайте ще
раз до вашої уваги qr-код будь ласка
шукайте цю інформацію і досліджуйте
ее наступне про що також важливо сказати
це про те що
надзвичайно важливо ділитися тим
досвідом який буде в кожного з нас
ділитися тими
ідеями своїми
думками і можливо
черпати ідеї від колег тому Запрошуємо
всіх приєднатися до Facebook спільноти
кateisн в Україні приєднатися ви до неї
також можете зараз коли ви перейдете за
Q
ркодо ця платформа була створена під час
пілотування проєкту пам'ятаєте ми
говорили Да що вже відбувся піло
пілотування цього проекту і була
створена ця ця спільнота тож будь ласка
зараз коли на стає все більше ми можемо
до неї приєднуватися і таким
чином ділитися всіми найкращими ідеями
також іще раз наголошуємо Що Ми ділимося
не лише світлина чи фрагментами роботи а
що надзвичайно важливо вашими рефлексіяю
вашими думками і вашим усвідомленням
того наскільки цінний Є проект
createning для цілісного розвитку дитини
тож будь ласка долучаємося Будьмо
активними і на сьогодні колеги ми вам
дуже
дякуємо за увагу і також пропонуємо
трішечки поміркувати зараз зафіксуйте
будь ласка у ваших
записниках три ключові ідеї три
відкриття якими були які для вас
значущими актуальними сьогодні
зафіксуйте їх у ваших записниках
згадуючи нашу зустріч
сьогодні
можливо це було із неs платформою із
тими ресурсами про які ми говорили з
тими ресурсами які можливо лежать і за
межами проекту createenising про якій
говорила сьогодні пані Оксана Рома будь
ласка все це згадайте і
зафіксуйте Наступне Що ми сьогодні
говорили про діє слова і про важливість
бути активними включеними діяти творити
І починати все це тут і зараз тому ми
вас просимо так само у ваших записниках
зафіксувати два своїх наступних кроки
які ви зробите У
проекті а також для того щоб отримати Ще
більше натхнення і
мотивації ми вас Запрошуємо у
чаті написати побажання для колег для
того щоб ці побажання допомогли нам
отримати більше мотивації і
натхнення будь ласка зараз міркуйте Що
би ви хотіли побажати колегам які разом
з вами будуть знайомитися з платформою
розпочинатиреалізовувати ідеї в межах
проекту creat enon будь ласка
поділіться і отримуйте ресурс від
побажань ваших
колег і ми приготували сьогоднішній день
Гудзика він має багато сюрпризів і ще
один сюрприз для вас
підготували по ляньте будь ласка зараз
на слайд оберіть той Гудзик який вам
сподобався зараз
найбільше Ви можете написати в чаті
номер
та ту цифру яка стоїть біля Гудзика будь
ласка і
зараз буде магічне зміна слайду і ви
можете знайти побажання саме для вас
від вашого
Гудзика кого перша був
Гудзик в кого п'ятий В кого третій будь
ласка Прочитайте свої
побажання і я думаю вони додадуть вам
розуміння до того які наступні кроки ви
можете зробити у реалізації проекту тож
Дякуємо колеги за вашу активність за
ваші відповіді у чаті
за нашу співдію і співпрацю і Я з
задоволенням передаю слово пані ольг
будь ласка пані Ольга щиро дякую пані
Олена щиро дякую Дорогі колеги я вам
хочу сказати що сьогодні наш чат
вибухнув педагогічними ідеями
креативними ідеями і Сьогодні ми з вами
отримали унікальний досвід який нам
презентувала команда The Lego foundation
а я б хотіла вам дати зворотній зв'язок
від наших учасників щодо сьогоднішньої
зустрічі узагальнити це важко взагалі
тому що дуже багато коментарів але
необхідно зазначити що сьогоднішня
зустріч дійсно надихаюча змістовна
практична професійна а також вона
зорієнтована не тільки на творців
майбутнього а на творців сьогодення які
сьогодні знаходяться з нами наші глядачі
відмітили що неймовірно практичний
ресурс і вже хотять спробувати
впроваджувати його в роботу дорогі
Колеги вам дуже дякують за гармони щастя
які ви подарували дуже дякують за те що
ви занурили в дитинство і дали
можливість нам сьогодні вирізати нам
сьогодні робити дива і всім всімвім дуже
сподобалася і щире вам подяка за
сьогоднішній день дуже багато запитань
було але на багато запитань ви вже дали
відповіді в своїх виступах але є деякі
на які б я хотіла з вашого дозволу
звернути вашу увагу і дати відповіді
нашим учасникам тож дорогі спікери
Скажіть будь ласка як долучитись до
проекта Lego foundundation в Україні чи
будуть розширення куди йти до кого
звертатися як зробити щоб бути разом з
вами пані окса напевно до вас Я думаю
мабуть та до мене це запитання Дякую за
запитання куди йти куди бігти Що писати
і Кому писати відповідаю наразі в нас
основний проект який є в Україні - це
проект сприяння світі і так як я
зазначила в нас є 300 закладів
дошкільної освіти у 15 областях України
до кінця 24го року ми розширимо цей
проект до 400 закладів відповідно в тих
10ти областях яких ми ще не присутні але
в нас десятки тисяч закладів освіти
дошкільної освіти в Україні і всі хочуть
якимось чином долучитися доторкнутися
мати в доступі матеріали тому те що ми
робимо однозначно ми не зможемо бути
присутні і до кожного педагога дійти
власною командою тому Один з аспектів -
це спецкурс педагогіка гри в
регіональних закладах післядипломної
освіти Де цей спецкурс повністю
написаний нашою командою наповнений
нашими матеріалами тому шановні педагоги
у вас уже зараз в планах реєстрації на
курси на наступний рік зверніть увагу
педагогіка гри у закладі дошкільної
освіти це той курс який розроблений нами
другий ресурс - Це програма про яку ми
зазначали на сайті мон у вільному
доступі потім ресурси які зазначали це
методичний посібник граємо разом онлайн
і офлайн взаємодії взаємодії з дітьми і
взаємодії з батьками ігрові взаємодії
маю на увазі і От такі проекти які ми
сьогодні презентували зокрема створюй з
будьчого потім я згадувала проект
соціально-емоційне емоційний розвиток
веселі друзі якого на наступний рік ми
будемо також виносити його на масову
практику це всі ті проекти які ми будемо
оприлюднювати через різні ресурси
заклади післядипломної освіти ресурси
Міністерства освіти ресурси українського
інститу тут у розвитку освіти і робити
їх доступними безкоштовними і вільними
найголовніше тут бажання відкрити
відкритий Розум і відкрите серце щиро
дякую і наші глядачі писали Коли ще
будуть такі зустрічі тому що такі
зустрічі надихають на роботу і створюють
середовище спілкування під час якого
можна обмінюватися досвідом знаходити
якісь такі родзинки для своєї
педагогічної діяльності і ще раз велика
вам подяка високодостойні колеги ще
питання є до вас е я знаю про те
що наразі програма граємо разом яку ви
сьогодні пані Оксано презентували вона
вже вийшла за межі України вона вже
Стала такою міжнародною і наразі ви вже
проводите навчання в інших країнах ми
Дуже радіємо і тішимося що досвід
України наразі впроваджується в інших
країнах чи могли б ви буквально коротко
щодо цього проговорити яким чином у нас
уже інші країни дізнаються про досвід
України
пані Олю надзвичайно Дякую за запитання
Я не знаю чи це тільки виключно ваше
запитання чи і тих учасників колег які у
нас сьогодні є в етері а нас багато
тисяч в етері і передусім слова подяки
нашим проектним закладам І взагалі
дошкіллі України наразі ми маємо проекти
у сусідніх з нами країнах у Румунії у
Молдові у Польщі і зокрема у Румунії у
Молдові є проекти у дошкіллі де з одного
боку Ми створюємо можливості для
неформальної освіти наших українських
дітей які вимушено перебувають за
кордоном а з іншого боку ми допомагаємо
румунській і молдовській системі освіти
дошкільної освіти інтегрувати
українських дітей у їхню формальну
систему освіти але оскільки наші діти
мали досвід ігрових взаємодій ігрового
ігрового розвитку тому ми на сьогодні
проводимо тренінги для усіх педагогів
закладів дошкільної освіти у цих країнах
і матеріали якими ми послуговуємося це
матеріали які розроблені і напрацьовані
командою Lego foundation спільно з
нашими українськими педаго ми і дуже
приємно от ви згадали посібник та граємо
разом сьогодні в руках мали можливість
тримати румунську версію цього посібника
з нашим українським досвідом і та криза
в якій перебуває сьогодні Україна це
також можливість не тільки зробити
багато позитивних трансформаційних змін
у нас всередині але також зробити такий
трансфер підходів трансфер досвіду
трансфер напрацювань далеко за межі
країни і сьогодні мала можливість
спілкуватися з румунськими коле ми
говорили про те що ми такі знаєте робимо
якийсь такий хаб ігрового ігрового
досвіду ігрової взаємодії педагогіки гри
у східній Європі і дуже приємно що ми
стаємо такими знаєте маяками у цьому
напрямку та тому колеги багато роботи
попереду але надзвичайно важливо що є
таке бажання і запит на цю роботу
Щиро дякуємо команді ле foundation за те
що ви робите за те що ви популяризуєте
кращий досвід України за те що ви розпо
вдаєте про нас і за те що дійсно Той
досвід який є з доведеною ефективністю
який опробований в закладах дошкільної
освіти України Вже може бути
популяризований і впроваджений в освіті
щира подяка щира подяка всій команді
злего foundation пані Оксано І от багато
закладів дошкільної освіти наразі
тимчасово не працюють знаходяться на
простої дуже
багато в дистанційному в змішаному
форматі працюють заклади освіти дуже
багато було запитань в нашому чаті які
стосуються саме цього ее напрямку
Скажіть будь ласка чи доречно е і
впроваджувати вашу програму яку ви
сьогодні презентували як це краще
зробити з чого починати Якщо можна дайте
будь ласка коментар дякую пані Олю за це
запитання це дуже слушне і актуальне
запитання і ми також отримуємо часто
запит на можливо є розроблені матеріали
для педагогів які працюють в
онлайн-режимі чи змішаному режимі один з
цих ресурсів ще раз зазначу та посібник
граємо разом початково Він робився саме
для онлайн взаємодій і від усіх
педагогів які працюють в онлайн
модальності ми знаємо що великий запит
також яким чином залучити батьків
зробити їх дотичними до гри з дітьми
тому в цих посібниках ще раз наголошу є
блок секція взаємодіємо з батьками
граємо з батьками де надані конкретні
ресурси матеріали навіть запитання для
батьків які вони можуть досліджувати
разом з дітьми А той проект який ми з
яким ми знайомились сьогодні створюю з
будь-чого картон упаковки з-під чавів
зпід пластівсів з-під будь-чого є у
кожного вдома це дуже легкий простий
інструмент до вас шановні педагоги
просто звернення познайомитися ближче з
цією платформою і просто дати покликання
для ваших батьків на цю платформу Хай
разом з дітям досліджують А за
можливості провести такий же самий
онлайн майстер-клас з батьками і я думаю
від цього виграємо ми всі разом з вами
100% і будемо чекати на ваші історії
успіху шановні наші педагоги яким чином
ви змогли познайомитися з платформою Як
ви впроваджуєте в свої діяльності
унікальний досвід І що ще хотілось би
сказати Що пані Оксано а доречно
педагогам також оздоблювати розширювати
форми методи роботи застосовуючи вашу
платформу як додатковий ресурс під час
роботи зз дітьми однозначно однозначно
це не та платформа яка має бути окремим
за заняттям чи в другу половину дня Це
та платформа яка стає ще одним із
інструментів одним з ресурсів у
ресурсній валізі нашого педагога якщо ми
бачимо що Працюємо з якоюсь казкою
читаємо казку оповідання і хочемо його
проілюструвати використовуючи саме цю
платформу будь ласка якщо ми хочемо
зробити такий креативний челендж
залучаючи дітей і батьків та креативні
шкарпетки чи креативні ялинки у нас
скоро будуть будь ласка Тобто це той
ресурс який можна використовувати де це
необхідно де це потрібно і де це буде
мати максимальну користь але надзвичайно
важливо щоб ми усвідомили не 25
однакових аплікацій а 25 пом на 10
можливостей для розвитку креативного
мислення для розвитку екологічної
свідомості кожної дитини Дякую наші
учасники пишуть прибираємо шаблони діємо
креативно
р хоча на цій платформі ви бачили та що
є там таке слово є таке слово як шаблони
але це шаблони які можна вирізати можна
обійтися без них це шаблони не дорівнює
тим шаблонам які аплікації тому не
копіюємо да не копіюємо з одного
грибочка 25 грибочків робимо 10 різних
моментів яким шляхів яким чином можна
зробити цю роботу Дорогі колеги я вам
дуже дякую пані оксина ще дуже багато
питань Скажіть будь ласка як іде
дізнатися більше про ігровий підхід у
закладах дошкільної освіти куди можна
звертатися але ви сказали що на сайті
міністерства освіти і науки є окрема
рубрика Дорогі наші глядачі будь ласка
завітайте 100% ви там знайдете багато
корисної інформації команда Z Leg
foundation має і парціальну програму яка
є грифованою на сьогоднішній день яка
відповідає базовому компоненту
дошкільної освіти дуже Ми дуже Ми
радіємо коли є ще такі матеріали з
доведеною ефективністю які команда Lego
foundation завжди щедро ділиться
популяризує саме для того щоб кожен
виховав кожен практичний психолог кожні
батьки мали можливість брати і
впроваджувати саме з кожною дитинкою щоб
це дійшло саме до кожної дитини дуже
цікаво і дуже важливо що це все йде
адресно Дорогі колеги і всі дякують
команді за Lego foundation за
сьогоднішню зустріч ви дійсно надихали
надихнули до того щоб ми діяли і для
того щоб ми творили час підбивати
підсумки пані Оксано та дякую пані Олю
підсумків може бути багато висновків
багато ми всі мали можливість
порефлексувати я також собі зафіксувала
та і кроки і дії які після
сьогоднішнього заходу потрібно робити І
ми в команді будемо також робити але
передусім хочу побажати нашим педагогам
власного ресурсу зрозуміти що коли ви не
в ресурсі це також Окей та як ми
сьогодні говоримо сказати що я не в
ресурсі сьогодні не можу мені потрібен
час перезарядитися відпочити від
новитися адже реалії в яких ми з вами
працюємо такі Візьміть для цього час
тому що коли ми йдемо для дітей Вони
очікують бачити перед собою запальничку
Вогник тому подбайте передусім про себе
і хочу ще раз звернутися та до того
курсу психосоціальної підтримки який є в
інститутах після дипломної освіти Я
сподіваюся що це стане вам в нагоді
по-друге ті ідеї які ви сьогодні почули
хай це стане як наші колеги зазначали
сьогодні трампліном такою першою точкою
до розширення можливостей і ідеї які є
на платформі створюю з будь-чого І
по-третє всі ми маємо усвідомити що
сьогодні час дійсно можливостей
можливостей для дошкільної освіти
можливостей для всіх ланок освіти і те
що ми з вами живемо і в цей направду
історичний час коли ми не тільки творимо
політики не тільки творимо документи які
стосуються дошкільної освіти Ми творимо
практики яких можливо до нас ніколи ще
ніхто не творив практики коли ми
працюємо в укриттях практики коли ми
працюємо з внутрішньо переміщеними
дітьми практики коли ми намагаємося
дійсно стати для всіх ресурсом і тому
наша ключова задача сьогодні була яку ми
ставили метою цього вебінару це для того
щоб ми для вас стали ресурсом сьогодні А
ви далі для того щоб стали ресурсом для
українських
дітей дякую пані Оксано щиро дякую
Дорогі колеги дякую пані Олю дякую пані
Олену за те що ви сьогодні дійсно для
нас стали тим ресурсом тією кисневою
маскою яка дозволяє нам творити і
рухатися учасники дякують команді за
Lego foundation міністерству освіти і
науки України українському інституту за
підтримку педагогів дошкілля України у
такий важкий час який наразі є Дякуємо
пані Оксано Дякуємо команді Lego
foundation за те що ви даєте можливість
брати участь у таких вебінарах здобувати
нові знання здобувати нові практики які
обов'язково стануть у нагоді у
педагогічній скринці кожного педагога
закладу шкільної освіти України не
втомлюємося дякувати ві Від усього серця
щоразу нашим захисникам за те що вони
боронять нашу рідну Україну вільно
незалежнону саме для того щоб дітки
здобували якісну дошкільну освіту миру
та Перемоги всім нам Бережіть себе бо
нам час святкувати перемогу Слава
збройним силам України слава Україні
миром
бути
for